muy bien me es hora de trabajar con el
problema número 13 el problema número 13
que por cierto está en la página 4 163
así que hola de nuevo y vamos a trabajar
el problema número 13 y como te dije el
problema número 13 tiene una tabla así
que vamos a hacerla de esta tabla tiene
solamente dos columnas así que me va a
quedar algo más o menos así no está tan
difícil de hacer esta tabla en esta
tabla estamos comparando la ciudad
entonces vamos a poner aquí ciudad
ciudad a comparación de su temperatura
al mediodía entonces aquí vamos a poner
su temperatura temperatura y está dada
en grados centígrados entonces vamos a
ponerle aquí grados centígrados y bueno
la primera ciudad es la ciudad am y esta
ciudad am tiene una temperatura de 50
grados centígrados
la ciudad ven por su parte a mediodía
tiene una temperatura de 33 grados
centígrados la ciudad se en la ciudad se
tiene 27 grados centígrados la ciudad de
la ciudad d tiene t grados centígrados y
aquí empieza lo bueno la ciudad en la
ciudad tiene 68 grados centígrados 68
grados centígrados la f 44 la f 44 y por
último a veces de vejez la ciudad
tiene 40 grados y además me dicen que la
mediana de todos estos datos es de 40
grados así que voy a apuntar lo aquí la
mediana la me
diana de todos estos datos son 40 grados
y lo que me preguntan es cuál de los
siguientes valores es un valor que no
puede tomar té y tengo como siempre 5
incisos así que antes de ver los incisos
vamos a ver qué significa que tengamos
una mediana de 40 grados y recuerda que
cuando nosotros hablamos de una mediana
estamos hablando del número que queda
justo en medio por lo tanto hay que
ordenar todos estos datos de mayor a
menor así que los voy a ordenar por aquí
el primer dato es 27 entonces para la
mitad 27 el segundo dato es 33 entonces
para la mitad y aquí voy a poner 33 el
siguiente es 40 entonces aquí voy a
poner 40 el siguiente es 44 entonces
permitan de aquí 44 el que sigue
50 entonces palomita y aquí voy a poner
50 y por último es 68 entonces este
último es 68 y ojo me dicen que mi
mediana es de 40 grados lo que quiere
decir que este es mi valor de mi mediana
y aquí ya empieza a sonar algo raro
porque si este es un valor de mi mediana
tiene que estar justo en medio y por un
momento empezamos a ver que no está
justo en medio de este lado hay tres de
este lado hay dos por lo tanto para que
la mediana sea 40 grados de la
temperatura que hay a mediodía en la
ciudad de debería de estar por acá es
decir que te debe de estar en este
conjunto de números para que mi mediana
sea 40 grados
deberíamos de tener de la temperatura
por aquí de tal manera que me quedaran
tres datos aquí tres datos acá y el
valor que está justo en medio es decir
mi mediana fuera 40 grados pero si te
das cuenta para qué
este aquí al ordenar los de menor a
mayor te tiene que ser un número menor
que 40 de hecho espera te tiene que ser
un número menor o igual que 40 porque si
fuera 40 aquí tendremos 27 33 40 40 44
50 68 y si fuera 40 déjame apuntarlo por
aquí si fuera 40 todavía me mediana
sería 40 tendremos tres números aquí
tres números a camps y el valor que está
justo en medio sigue siendo 40 por lo
tanto te puede ser cualquier número
menor que cuarenta y cuarenta y
solamente para recordar recuerda que la
mediana es el que está en
muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué dice mis
incisos para ver cuál de ellos no es un
valor que podría tomar tema es decir un
valor menor o igual que 40 y el inciso a
dice 29 29 es menor que 40 por lo tanto
el inciso am si es un valor válido para
t el inciso b dice 35 también es un
valor válido para t el inciso c dice 39
también es un valor válido para t el
inciso de dice 40 pero nosotros sabemos
que 40 también funciona por lo tanto
también el ciso t es un valor válido
para t mientras que por último inciso m
dice 42 y es justo el valor que no puede
tomar tema para que se sigan cumpliendo
las hipótesis de este problema en la
mediana sea 40 ya tenemos aquí la
respuesta de este problema número 13 así
que vamos a hacer el problema siguiente
el problema número 14 el cual dice
problema 14 y el problema 14 parece
bastante interesante así que déjame
hacerlo por aquí
déjame poner un cuadro bastante
interesante me gusta este color para
decir que es un color interesante y
tengo una figura más o menos así tengo
algo x así y después tengo algo por acá
y después tengo algo parecido a esto que
sube por aquí pero suben más si es algo
justo así perfecto y esta es la figura
que me dan y por cierto me dan algunos
datos lo que me dicen es que y déjame
cambiar de color lo que me dicen es que
este lado este mide 6 este lado 1016
este es un ángulo de 90 grados este
también es un ángulo de 90 grados este
lado mide 6 este lado mide 6 y además me
dicen que este ángulo mide 30 grados y
este otro ángulo mide 30 grados y lo que
me preguntan es cuál es el perímetro de
esta figura yo lo que quiero saber es
cuál es el perímetro de esta figura pero
este problema está padrísimo porque
darte cuenta de lo siguiente la primera
forma de pensar en resolver este
problema sería hacer una línea por aquí
y entonces como sabemos que este punto
está justo a la mitad
podremos sacar un triángulo rectángulo
aquí otro triángulo rectángulo aquí y
sacar la hipotenusa etcétera etcétera
etcétera pero hay una forma más
entretenida y más padre de hacer todo
este problema así que déjame quitar esto
de aquí la forma entretenida es pensar
en la figura contraria es decir invertir
esta figura y me voy a fijar más bien en
este triángulo este triángulo de aquí
este voy a hacer una línea por acá que
no me estorba la otra
por acá me falta y después voy a hacer
una línea por acá debe fijar en este
triángulo amarillo este triángulo
amarillo que se de el bueno cuánto mide
este ángulo si es triángulo mide 30
grados entonces todo esto debe de medir
90 grados
y cuánto me falta para llegar a los 90
grados pues me faltan 60 grados y por
esta parte tengo termina un ángulo de 90
grados aquí ya tengo 30 entonces me
faltan también 60 grados y adivina que
60 más 60 son 120 para 180 este ángulo
mide también 60 grados y por lo tanto
estamos hablando de un triángulo
equilátero es un triángulo equilátero
porque sus tres ángulos son iguales y
además yo sé que esta distancia mide 6
que es la misma que está esta distancia
mide 6 porque estamos hablando de un
cuadrado estos tres lados miden lo mismo
sus ángulos en ángulos rectos y por lo
tanto es un cuadrado y esta distancia
mide 6
ahora regresemos a este triángulo de
amarillo si es un triángulo equilátero
entonces este mide 6 y este esto también
va a medir 6 i estem esto también va a
medir 6 porque en un triángulo
equilátero todos sus ángulos miden lo
mismo y todos sus lados miden lo mismo
está
padrísimo esto porque ahora qué crees
fíjate en lo siguiente si yo lo que
quiero sacar es el perímetro de esta
figura rosa que tengo en un principio
entonces pues éste no cuenta está
ahorita no lo voy a apelar y solamente
me voy a quedar con este 6 este 6 estas
6 este 6 y este 6 es decir 6 x 1 2 3 4 5
el perímetro es igual a 6 x 5 lo cual es
30 y entonces ya tengo el perímetro que
por cierto es el insisto de así que este
estuvo muy padre y vámonos al siguiente
problema problema número 15 que es el
siguiente y dice así a m es el factor
primo más grande de 38 vamos a apuntar
lo aquí m es el factor premium es el
factor primo
primo
más grande más grande de 38 más grande
de 38 muy bien
por otra parte n es el factor primo más
grande de 100 en esta ocasión es el más
grande de 100 y lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale m más n entonces
esencialmente lo que hay que hacer y
para mi sistema es el procedimiento más
fácil es factorizar en primos estos dos
números es decir 38 quién es bueno 38 lo
podemos escribir como 38 tiene mitad
entonces la mitad de 38 es 19 igual jaua
está bien padre porque 19 es un número
primo entonces 19 es decir que 38 es lo
mismo que 2 x
19 vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con el
100 el ciento si lo descomponemos en
primos pues que me dan
bueno pues si en tiene mitad la mitad de
100 es 50-50 también tiene mitad la
mitad de 50 es 25 y entonces vámonos por
primos 2 es primo 3 es primo pero 25 no
tiene tercera a 5 es primo entonces 25
tiene quinta la quinta de 25 es 5 y 5
también tiene quinta la quinta de 5 es 1
perfecto por lo tanto podemos decir que
100 es exactamente lo mismo que 2 por 2
por 5 por 5 ahora fíjate que el primo
más grande de los factores de 38 es 19 y
el primo más grande de los factores de
100 es 5 por lo tanto 19 más 5 esto es
lo mismo que 24 y 24 es el inciso c
por lo tanto ya está aquí está el
problema número 15 y vamos a resolver el
siguiente problema el problema número 16
así que trabajemos con el problema
número 16 que dice lo siguiente en el
plano cartesiano la recta el plano
cartesiano vamos a dibujar un plano
cartesiano por aquí a este me gusta como
un plano cartesiano esto es un eje de
leyes por aquí tengo a mi eje de las x
muy bien y este es el eje y este es el
eje x y lo que me dicen es que la recta
l tiene una pendiente positiva y pasa
por el punto cero cero pasa por el punto
cero cero y tiene una pendiente positiva
es decir pasa por el origen y se va a
ver más o menos así esto de aquí es mi
recta l esta es mi recta l y después me
dicen si la recta k es perpendicular a
la recta e le vamos a poner por aquí a
mi recta cam
con este color es una recta
perpendicular no sabemos por dónde pasa
exactamente la recta cam lo que sí sé es
que la recta k es perpendicular por lo
tanto este ángulo es recto
esta es mi recta cam entonces cuál de
las siguientes afirmaciones es siempre
verdadera y bueno no he visto los
incisos pero a mí me suena que en este
ejercicio
necesitamos un conocimiento previo
acerca de las pendientes de dos rectas
perpendiculares si l
déjame ver si l supongo que tiene una
ecuación voy a decir que tiene la
siguiente ecuación él entiende la
ecuación que es igual a m una pendiente
por x + b bueno de hecho no tiene por
qué pasa por el origen por lo tanto es
la ecuación de la recta l y es igual a
mx
entonces la recta cam que sabemos la
recta cam la recta k tiene como ecuación
la siguiente y es igual y la pendiente
de la recta cam
es el inverso multiplicativo negativo de
está pendiente es decir es 1 / m que es
el inverso multiplicativo de m pero
negativo cuando tengo dos rectas
perpendiculares pasa lo siguiente las
pendientes son inversas multiplica tibás
y además una es positiva y la otra es
negativa entonces se vería más o menos
así y es igual a menos 1 entre m por x +
b y bueno digo más b porque no
forzosamente tiene que pasar por el
origen no me dicen eso puede pasar por
cualquier otro punto de la recta l
entonces ahora sí vamos a ver los
incisos cual las siguientes afirmaciones
es siempre verdadera el inciso am me
dice que a ver espera el inciso a me
dice que la recta k pasa por el origen
pero eso no forzosamente es cierto
busquemos la importante la importante es
que la pendiente tiene que ser una
positiva y la otra negativa es decir la
recta que debe de tener pendiente
por cierto aquí está aquí esta es el
insisto 12 el inciso se me dice que la
pendiente de la recta que debe ser
forzosamente negativa ya está así que se
me ha acabado el tiempo y nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima